في عام 2023 العمل من المنزل بدلا من
زياده الرواتب هل مازلتم ترغبون في العمل
من المنزل حسنا هناك اخبار ساره المديرون
في شركات كثيره يبحثون جديا عن استمرار
هذا الخيار لموظفهم او التوظيف من خلاله
العمل المقبل لكن مهلا هل تعرفون لماذا
السبب هو زياده الاجور ففي مثل هذه
الاوقات من نهايه السنه تبدا المناورات
بين الموظفين وباب العمل على زياده
السنويه المرتقبه لرواتبهم في العام
الجديد البونس والحوافز وزياده الرواتب
وغيرها وفي ظل الارتفاع في اسعار السلع
والخدمات في كل مكان في العالم يتجه
الموظفون الى طلب زياده كبيره في رواتبهم
في عام 2003 2020 لكن لتفادي ذلك قررت
شركات كثيره ابقاء خيار العمل من المنزل
كحلين لعدم رفع الرواتب خصوصا ان التوقعات
تشير الى ان 2003 وعشرين قد يكون عاما
سيئا اقتصاديه والشيء بالشيء يذكر بخصوص
التوظيف الجديد هناك شركات كثيره ترغبوا
اكثر فا بالتوظيفي عن بعد العمل المقبل
يصبح التوظيف عن بعد للشركات بتوفير ما
يصل الى 15% من مدفوعات الرواتب والخبر
الملفت في هذا السياق هو ان ارباب العمليه
يبحثون عن موظفين في مناطق بعيده عن المدن
حيث الاجور اقل لذا اذا كنت تسكن بعيدا عن
المدينه فقد تكون امامك فرصه في العام
الجديد وانت لو اتيحت لك فرصه العمل عن
بعد هل ستقبل بها براتب اقل ام تفضل العمل
من مكتبك براتب اعلى اكتب لنا اجابتك في
التعليقات
[موسيقى]